hey guys you've probably already noticed
that of all the dragon ball YouTubers on
here I've never really reviewed each
individual episode of super and by never
really I mean I never did like ever and
seeing as we are already years into
Super's episodic run I don't expect you
to sit through 76 10 minute reviews of
episodes you've already seen the reviews
for then I stumbled upon this channel
called Jello apocalypse and besides
possibly having the best channel name in
existence he caught my attention with
one video in particular that being every
Disney film reviewed in 10 words or less
where he reviewed 60 Disney films rapid
fire within 10 words or less so
naturally I thought that's a great idea
for a video and it solved my problem of
how to catch up with all those other
pesky Dragon Ball YouTubers as of making
this video there are currently 76 Dragon
Ball super episodes available for my
viewing pleasure all scores will be
whole numbers out of 10 which means
there will be no numbers like 9.5 and
there might be a negative score or two
now that doesn't mean that it's worse
than a 0 out of ten no instead it
measures its ironic enjoyment nothing in
my opinion is worse than boring so if
episode has spawned enjoyment from
ripping on how terrible it is then
terrific that means it qualifies for
negative scoring because you can make
fun of it and sometimes that's more fun
than just a boring episode These scores
will take into account all aspects of
the show including but not limited to
visuals and narrative now that that's
out of the way let's review every Dragon
Ball super episode in 10 words or less
what is this real
actually happening
missed opportunity for Vegeta to wear a
certain pink shirt Frieza vs Goku
flashback now with Gorgeous modern
animation techniques Goten Trunks and
peel off filler nonsense repeat for 12
minutes pretty much the reason I have
any subscribers at all emotional
flashbacks make beerus a more credible
and Rich character Vegeta's power from
Battle of Gods now with no budget rock
paper stall for Goku hey videos of Super
Saiyan said way too many people watching
Goku learn to harness his new abilities
is fun a huge Improvement on animation
suspense and action there's definitely a
fisting joke here somewhere Mr Satan's
the bravest character in this Arc the
movie might have looked better but this
fight is just better because of one joke
I now love this episode excellent
character acting made for exceptional
episodes
oh yeah hilarious and totally
underappreciated I loved everything
about this episode easily the most
terrifying interpretation of hell I've
ever seen huh I didn't know Jocko worked
in episode 24 Frieza represents the arc
taguma represents the viewers attention
span that moment you realize you can use
the most inspirational character the
most unenthusiastic boring murder I've
ever seen [ __ ] okay this feels like a
personal attack on my Integrity freeze
is not the only one getting tired of
this whisa's do-over means there's an
alternate timeline where Frieza wins
tournament 12 universes
[ __ ] Bulma is a sister
yeah okay you can't spell recap without
boba's boobs or Super Dragon Balls which
will you remember what has beards an
evil Winnie the Pooh this episode wait
no but what oh I get it Frost's an
[ __ ] and he's gone hey look a robot
it's always great to see the Final Flash
fun episode full of Great Character
moments for Vegeta why has no one
mentioned his hands a giant penis
important episode that reminded us why
we watched this show I forgot that this
was basically a tournament for food poor
animation ruins what could have been a
huge moment really fun episode with
surprise beerus rematch Goku lost his
key how will he ever get in it's mini
Arc time I for one welcome her new
jelita Overlord funny touching and much
better than golden frieza's fight one of
the best dragon ball episodes ever made
1000 minus Good carry the just go back
to the fight bed I guess you could say
trunks missed the point spontaneous into
dimensional time vortexes cutting Great
Moments shorts since tooth if bullets
did nothing to Raditz what's it like for
black that moment the crushing
disappointment of Gohan hits you zamasu
the story of the Barista that became
space Hitler let me help you son plow's
face into the ground God I love this
little [ __ ] how does Super Saiyan Rose
work who cares
cares some exciting suspenseful and
really polished episode also GodTube
Step 1 for good feng shui put table
middle holy crap when beerus turns it on
it's on Wilma's dinner parties really
put the Last Supper to shame probably
the best transformation since Dragon
Ball Z map of us cool but didn't deliver
in the last episode's climax polished
with epic moments but Maya's plan is so
dumb trunks you have the power holy [ __ ]
he actually does apparently beams only
work if you're the main protagonist the
amount of pure action this episode has
is astounding unexpectedly somber end to
a really fun Arc quirky little episode
where Bulma gives beerus and wheeze
crabs Goku would totally kick saitama's
ass right guys
guys that empty void in my life has
suddenly been filled wait what Goku's
dead oh he's not
neat I can show you the world
shining shimmering splendid quickly
great Saiyan man stop any Brock I mean
Barry Khan daddy why are you a [ __ ]
Shingeki no Dragon Ball and that's all
of them as of recording this video now
naturally I don't expect you to want to
go back through this list to see which
ones are the best and the worst so here
are my top and bottom five Dragon Ball
super episodes top five number five
episode 57 this is the kind of episode
that will bring a smile to your face
featuring the best animation of this Arc
it brings tons of action with her main
characters either down or cornered and
never leaves you waiting for something
to happen unless what you're waiting for
is nothing number four episode 18
presenting possibly the funniest episode
in the series this one follows Goku and
Vegeta as they train together with whis
in an assortment of different and fun
scenarios it's a shame this is buried in
an arc that almost everyone will skip
because it's easily one of the best
number three episode 39 this is is the
episode that turns the awesome from 10
to 25 featuring the climax to the
tournament no monaka doesn't count
bringing fan fictions across the world
to Life Goku uses the Kaioken in tandem
with his Super Saiyan blue form
delivering a moment no Dragon Ball fan
will ever forget number 2 episode 66
described by many of the best looking
episode in Dragon Ball history this
Behemoth of an episode crams two battles
into its run time and acts as the climax
to the arc featuring The Return of
Vegito briefly and a spirit sword
wielded by trunks does it make sense of
course not but look pretty pictures and
the number one best episode so far goes
to episode 47 haunting new scores
accompany a darker plotline delivers an
intense episode following up for the
first time of the series with Future
Trunks as he flees an imposing shadowy
figure this was exactly the kind of
episode Dragon Ball super needed when it
came out the visuals stunning The
Narrative captivating and the stakes
were extremely hot if you're unsure
about checking out super or know someone
who's on the fence I can't recommend a
single episode more it's that good but
who cares about the best of anything
right if my worst video I mean my worst
moments video is anything to go by
people only really want to know how
horrible something is because nothing's
more fun than basking the abuse of
someone else's content so here we go the
bottom five number five episode four
this guy avoids criticism by existing
next to the meme Factory that is episode
5. and what it largely looks better
that's where the pros end at least
episode 5 continued The Narrative this
serves only to Pat out a story that
desperately needed more character
development more than the PF gang
looking for food anyway number four
episode 12.
you guys want to know what filler in a
fight looks like this amidst the Battle
of the Gods comes this wonderful little
gem of an episode featuring key dragons
and fist clashes between Goku and beerus
that threatened to shatter the entire
universe I know what you're thinking
well that's dumb and doesn't make sense
at all
number three episode 25 filled with
absolutely nothing original except bad
art animation and a fight that feels
longer than the first even though it's a
fraction of its length this episode
offers nothing except a new form of
cruel and unusual torture number 2
episode 30. this is one of those recap
episodes but the biggest difference is
that it covers events that literally
just happened this is an episode that
exists purely to give the animators
breathing room to make the next episode
a couple of scenes here and there with
Goku Vegeta keep this from being a one
out of 10. and the absolute worst
episode is episode 24. this is the
absolute worst of the worst when I think
of a bad or downright terrible Dragon
Ball installment this abortion of an
episode Springs to mind episode 5 spawns
some hilarious spoofs and had undeniably
albeit brief Great Moments this episode
arguably looks worse and the only thing
you've realized is that you've wasted 22
minutes of your life watching two
scribbles clumsily stumble their way
through it narrative forcing you to
question why are you even watching this
in the first place ice
[Music]